le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
un collège c'est évidemment d'abord un
lieu d'éducation et d'enseignement
mais ce n'est pas sa seule dimension
c'est aussi un lieu de vie qui doit être
le plus agréable possible pour que
l'enseignement seul mieux accepter le
mieux diffuser mais ce n'est pas
toujours simple dans une société urbaine
comme la nôtre avec des établissements
parfois assez anciens et où l'on a
souvent que peu de temps et de moyens a
consacré à l'environnement
alors comment intégrer la nature à notre
décor quotidien comment en profiter pour
sensibiliser aussi les plus jeunes aux
questions environnementales
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
le collège teixeira da mota est un
collège construit il y a maintenant 14
ans à l'origine ce collège a été
construit sans arbres ou espaces verts
dans son enceinte en partenariat avec
d'autres structures
le collège s'est lancé dans un projet
d'embellissement globale du site ap les
po2 ou p o car est un projet qui
implique et qui concernent chacun des
membres de cette structure
alors il ya plusieurs actions menées à
l'intérieur du projet p o car est
notamment des actions liées à
l'embellissement du collège et la
revégétalisation
du collège qui est plutôt minérale et
nous voudrions le rendre davantage
végétal le trajet po2 est imposée qui a
été mis à dans le collège cette année ça
s'est super bien passé puisque 20 on a
tous voulu apporter un peu de verdure
dans ce collège et ça a permis
d'apporter ce qui manquait à ses
collèges donc ça nous plaît bien tous
les élèves ce projet paix au carré était
rendue possible avec le soutien à la
collaboration de nos partenaires bien
entendu le conseil général qui finance
au sein du collège
la partie embellissement puisque nous
participons concours collège fleury donc
par le biais d'une attributs d'une
subvention financière nous avons pu
notamment avancer notre projet parce
qu'il avait quand même des choses à
acheter du matériel et donc le conseil
général nous soutient financièrement
grâce au conseil général leur action a
pu prendre tournant concret grâce à leur
participation au concours collège
fleuries organisé pour la seconde année
consécutive par le conseil général
ce concours réunit une vingtaine de
collèges partout à la réunion
les enjeux de ce projet et par extension
de ce concours sont capitaux il s'agit
de sensibiliser chacun à la cause
environnementale tout en améliorant le
cadre de vie et de travail de chacun
mais aussi de responsabiliser des élèves
parfois en mal être briefé d'ici et
après et là on en train de consommer
mieux ferrato taux de chômage dans
retrait et on aura un volcan aussi et
acoss
on prendra des des flux sur le côté je
suis professeur en classes relais c'est
une classe qui accueille des jeunes
risque d'exclusion où on risque de
marginalisation et donc
nous avons intégré le projet po2 que le
collège teixeira mettait en place donc
comme outil de formation comme outil de
préparation aussi de socialisation des
jeunes par rapport à la vie active j'ai
eu toute une habitude qui a dû être
prise comme un qui a dû s'installer 2
travail et de montrer qu'on est fiers de
notre résultat de le présenter aux
autres on a des jeunes qui
photographient le travail pour se
présenter à leurs parents c'est déjà pas
mal dans les récréations aujourd'hui on
s'arrête plus il continue de travailler
pour montrer un ensemble du collège qui
sont qui sont bien dans leurs démarches
et c'est vraiment plaisant que je suis
un connard on est en train d'inverser
complètement un rapport à la fierté à
l'autonomie à l'envi 2
de montrer aussi qu'on est des gens bien
quand on a aussi cette capacité là
d'être man band être bon niveau
technique et artistique
pour nassimah dindar il n'y a que des
points positifs à ce concours grâce à la
subvention du conseil général le collège
teixeira da mota est plus que jamais en
passe de réussir son projet et pourquoi
pas de remporter le concours c'est le
travail de chaque membre de
l'organisation du collège ainsi que de
ses élèves qui rendent possible
l'embellissement et l'amélioration du
cadre de vie de chacun
c'est surtout l'occasion de permettre
aux plus jeunes de s'intéresser à
l'environnement enjeu majeur pour
l'avenir
l'opération collèges fleury est une
belle opération pour conseil général
porte dans vingt collèges avec un triple
objectif nous voulons sensibiliser les
jeunes à la problématique de la nature à
leur environnement parce que c'est vrai
que travailler dans un lieu venir à
l'école au collège dans un vieux beau
fleury c'est quand même plus intéressant
plus motivant que d'avoir des murs
parfois un peu terne et en même temps il
ya derrière cela un projet pédagogique
puisque les enseignants mais également
les élèves avec le conservatoire
botanique de mascarin qui est un outil
du conseil général peuvent partager sur
les plantes médicinales connaître
également les plantes d'antan et puis
aussi les jolies fleurs pour avoir
autour de soi un cadre bien plus
agréable
le conseil général a vu juste en mettant
en place un concours motivant et
constructif le projet collège fleury
réunit tous les élèves et les
sensibilisent à cette cause majeure pour
le futur quel environnement
il est également fédérateur car il
permet à tous de s'impliquer et de
découvrir les métiers de l'environnement
ce concours permet de s'impliquer pour
soi pour son collège pour les autres
mais également pour les générations
futures est donc de construire la
réunion de demain le conseil général de
la réunion vous a présenté lien social
le conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais